Sharkey: So one of the things
I've learned
as I've been jumping
into Android
is about
all of the features
that you can
really take advantage of,
and one of those
is stateful drawables.
Now, I've come from
a Swing background in Java,
and so I'm used to, okay,
let's say I have
a button on the screen,
and when the user clicks
on that button,
or maybe they mouse over it,
I want that icon to change,
uh, to maybe
an inverted icon.
Uh, so the way
I'd write that in Swing
is you'd write
an onClick listener
or an onMouseOver--
a mouse move listener
to watch for those actions
and then swap out the image.
Um, but with Android,
you don't have to write those.
With stateful drawables,
you can have a single image
that changes the image it--
that changes what it is
based on the state.
So I don't have
to write that code.
As the user
moves over something,
or when they touch something,
or as they check an item,
that i--that image
automatically changes for me.
A second thing
I've really found valuable
is the Hierarchy Viewer.
I've found myself
a lot of times
as I'm trying
to lay out a view
and really see how things work
on the screen,
that it doesn't look
the way I want it to.
Something's not working out.
And so many times,
instead of just
tweaking little changes
one at a time
to see, you know,
"How can I fix this?
How can I make this layout
work the way I want it to?"
I can use
the Hierarchy Viewer
to really drill down and see
how things are being
laid out on the device,
where the boundaries
of the objects are,
so that I can clearly see
where things
are being laid out
and how I could reorganize
to solve the problem
and fix the view to make it
the way I want it.